[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon if you'd like to help
me make more political content consider
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
second thought these are the images that
have now been seen across the country
angry protesters some of them armed
spilling into the Capitol in Michigan
demanding the country reopen some of
those protests very heated some
demonstrators armed and the president
tonight defending some of those
protesters this morning a battle brewing
over reopening the country as
demonstrations grew louder from coast to
coast if you go by the news coverage of
the recent reopen America protests it
would seem like there's a legitimate
movement pushing for an end to pandemic
mitigation measures surely these crowds
of hardworking Americans all came
together organically to support a cause
they all genuinely believe in right not
even close
in this episode we're gonna talk about
astroturfing the term astroturf
referring to the fake grass alternative
is a play on the word grassroots as in
organically formed movements
astroturfing is the practice of hiding
the sponsors or organizers of a group or
movement to try to make it appear that
it's run and supported by grassroots
participants the term was coined in 1985
by Texas state senator Lloyd Bentsen
who said a fella from Texas can tell the
difference between grassroots and
astroturf this was referring to a
mountain of supposedly organic mail that
all just happened to align with
insurance industry interests
astroturfing is explicitly a propaganda
operation the goal isn't necessarily to
create a group that can do anything by
itself but rather to craft the illusion
of public consensus around a subject
usually one that aligns with the
interests of a powerful group like the
oil and gas industry a political party
or the country itself studies of modern
astroturfing have shown that these
operations can and do influence public
opinion enough to make a difference in
legislation you're probably thinking
surely that's illegal right people and
corporations spending huge amounts of
money to forge public consent
technically yes many countries including
the US do have laws prohibiting the
practice but I'm sure you won't be
surprised to learn that it happens
anyway there are even private companies
you can hire to build a movement for you
including actors to pretend to be
protesters security or paparazzi and
software to run campaigns where you can
pose as dozens or hundreds of different
people you want
world to think that it's really a you
know genuine crowd and that's what we do
in theory it's illegal but those with
vast pools of money do it all the time
the United States itself ran an
operation called earnest voice where the
federal government ran a propaganda
campaign using fake accounts to spread
pro-american sentiment in foreign
countries what we're seeing today with
the reopen America protests is a clear
example of astroturfing but before we
get to that let's look at a few past
examples of Astroturf movements in the
mid to late 90s when anti-smoking
legislation was starting to become more
commonplace Philip Morris
burson-marsteller and other tobacco
groups came together to form the
National smokers Alliance they launched
a massive public relations campaign to
try to exaggerate grassroots support for
smokers rights though they had some
success this was still a couple years
before the internet really became a
useful tool for astroturfing and
organizing the internet particularly
email really started to make a
difference in 2001 when Microsoft was
slapped with a well deserved antitrust
lawsuit the group Americans for
technology leadership or ATL funded
heavily by Microsoft started an
astroturf letter-writing campaign the
group contacted constituents under the
guise of conducting a poll identified
Microsoft supporters and sent them
letters to send to the relevant law
makers the goal was to make it appear as
though the public wanted leniency for
Microsoft in the antitrust ruling
environmental issues is where we've
really seen a lot of astroturf ink this
shouldn't be surprising considering the
incredible wealth and power of the
fossil fuel industry and how apparent it
is that they're making the planet
unlivable they need these operations to
keep public outrage below the boiling
point the Koch brothers and the Kennedy
family started a public advocacy group
to oppose the building of wind farms in
Massachusetts huge alliances of oil and
gas companies ramped up disinformation
campaigns to mobilize the public against
environmental regulations after the 2008
presidential election in Canada oil and
gas company executives banded together
to form the Canadian Association of
Petroleum Producers and attempted to use
social media campaigns and mainstream
media offensives to garner public
support for fossil fuels opponents tend
to be much more vocal in opposition to
the industry and so it's really
important that we bring people together
who are all supportive of the industry
so they have the ability to also speak
out in favor of it each time special
interest groups relied on fake support
to make it appear as though their
movement was legitimate but perhaps the
most infamous instance of astroturfing
in recent times has been the entire
existence of the Tea Party it's a bit of
a convoluted story so buckle up after
the 1993 election of Bill Clinton the
Republicans were spooked not only had
the Democrats taken the White House they
also had control of both houses of
Congress one man Jeff Nesbitt had worked
in Bush senior's administration and had
found himself without a job so he turned
to consulting one of his clients was a
group called citizens for a sound
economy or CSE they were a small group
with a surprisingly large checkbook
Nesbitt was curious about their sources
of funding and it eventually became
apparent that the ultra wealthy Koch
brothers were behind the operation
when Koch lieutenant Richard Fink
started showing up at strategy meetings
and talking about what the brothers
wanted back then it wasn't apparent what
CSE's overarching goal was but with the
benefit of hindsight it's become more
clear the seemingly rapid and
unpredictable rise of the Tea Party was
anything but the Koch family some of the
richest people on the planet had played
the long game to establish a political
movement that would drive public opinion
to the right forcing their interests
into the public conversation thankfully
now a mostly ignored fringe group there
was a moment when it seemed like the tea
party could completely infiltrate the
Republicans and make it the Koch party
not that it makes much of a difference
today because the Republican Party is
basically the tea party now and the
Democrats are the Republicans of the
1990s but that's a topic for another
video
one of Nesbit's first assignments was to
meet with a giant corporate partner in
New York these guys were big and they
knew what they were doing when it came
to building astroturf campaigns
you might recognize their name from
earlier philip morris one of the largest
tobacco interests the two groups each
liked what the other brought to the
table and forged an alliance to create
astroturfed anti-tax groups that would
oppose any and all taxes anywhere in the
country the goal was to weaponize public
dislike a taxation to build a fake
movement that opposed the government's
ability to pay for its projects
including climate change mitigation when
there weren't enough real people to
protest attacks the Koch brothers and
tobacco lobby would direct their
employees to stand in to give the
appearance of a real movement the two
groups went on to form more anti
regulation propaganda operations get
government's off our back enough is
enough and citizens against regressive
taxation
none of these were organic move
despite their being covered as such
there's no doubt that the grassroots Tea
Party energy is stirring Republican
hopes and dreams from big gains in
Congress this November by the time Obama
took office the Tea Party was ready to
burst onto the scene back then it
appeared like it had come out of nowhere
a popular uprising in the face of unjust
government overreach but this was all
planned from the beginning by the
largest private oil company and the
largest cigarette company all to save
them money undermine climate action and
attempt to bend one of the two major
political parties to their will but to
fast forward to today knowing what we
now know about astroturfing
do the reopen America protests seem
legitimate to you why does it seem like
America wants to go back to work when
polling shows that an overwhelming
majority of the public 95 percent of
Democrats and 70 percent of Republicans
support a nationwide stay at home order
there's your first red flag
public opinion does not support these
protests despite their coverage in the
media a number of cyber security experts
and Internet detectives have done some
digging and surprise surprise of the
hundreds of new domains using the word
reopen most of them traced back to
extreme gun rights advocates lobbyists
and prominent conservative groups for
example some of the largest anti
quarantined Facebook groups including
all of the X State against successive
quarantine come from the same three
people these people brothers aaron
christopher and ben dor are far-right
activists who believe that the nra is
too liberal
they created individual Facebook pages
for many states and launched a
disinformation campaign to manipulate
locals into joining their cause they're
known for trying to incite people to
liberate their states by threatening
lawmakers congregate outside without
masks and help to spread their anti
regulatory agenda by distributing false
information the door brothers are also
behind a slew of reopened websites
reopen MN com redirects to Minnesota gun
rights org part of their extremists gun
Network reopened PA calm is registered
to the same person and links to the
Pennsylvanians against excessive
quarantine Facebook page one of the
brothers Aaron is a registered lobbyist
for the state of Iowa
besides the door brothers other reopened
sites are linked to Freedom Works a
conservative action group that used to
go by a name you probably remember
citizens for a sound economy and
reopened Mississippi calm is registered
to in pursuit of LLC a conservative
group with
number of former employees who now work
at the White House Michigan has been a
hot spot for astroturfed protests and
some of the largest gatherings were
organized by the Michigan conservative
coalition headed by a former Republican
lawmaker and his wife who is now a
member of the Trump advisory board and
the women for Trump coalition the
Michigan protests were also promoted and
amplified by the Michigan freedom fund
another conservative group headed by
Greg McNeely an advisor to the DeVos
family Betsy DeVos is Trump's Secretary
of Education other well-known groups
funding anti lockdown protests are the
Heritage Foundation and the coke funded
Americans for Prosperity but people are
starting to connect the dots
now that we've understood for many years
how the internet can be weaponized and
used as a tool for manufacturing consent
people are able to more quickly spot
astroturfing when it arises one
journalist Jeremy Scahill recently made
an observation about the DeVos family
including Betsy DeVos his brother Eric
Prince the founder of Blackwater a
private military company he said they
have a long record of financing the most
dangerous right-wing extremist
individuals and causes in the country
they gave the seed money to the radical
religious right poured money into
anti-choice groups and are funding the
current coronavirus protests this type
of reporting is critical to spotting
astroturfed movements and explaining the
motives behind them luckily so far the
reopen America protests don't seem to
have made much of an impact on public
opinion of course there were plenty of
stupid selfish people congregating at
the beach for Memorial Day weekend but
that's just typical American entitlement
and unwillingness to be inconvenienced
one bizarre thing to note about the last
couple rounds of right-wing culture war
offensives has been just how willing
they are to risk their own health to own
the libs the anti-vaccination
preventable diseases the reopen America
protesters are just begging to catch
coronavirus and by their own actions
cause more people to die and require
that the lockdown be extended even
longer of course this doesn't matter to
the corporations and dark money groups
behind the protests they don't care how
many gullible people actually buy into
their propaganda and end up dying the
only goal is to shift public opinion to
benefit their bottom line or for the
conservative groups to maintain control
of government so that they can accept
more donations from the group's funding
the protests and the cycle continues and
before you write me a novel in the
comments about how I'm a liberal cook
please hear this the Democrats are not
much better than
Republicans they take oil and gas money
too it's just in this particular round
of astroturfing
it's the conservative groups at the
reins but regardless of who's behind
these false movements just be aware that
it's a very common practice those in
power will always use that power to keep
it the interests of the people are not
important to multibillion-dollar
corporations and by extension not
important to our elected officials by
whom they are heavily funded we as
citizens deserve the right to be
represented by people who will enforce
our will not the will of billionaires
and the most destructive industries on
earth pay attention to the astroturfing
look who's behind it those people are
not our friends if you enjoyed this
video and you'd like to see more like it
consider subscribing to stay up to date
with my latest episodes if you hated it
go ahead and drop a thumbs down and if
you really want to help support my
channel I recently started a patreon
which you can find at patreon.com slash
second thought you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen thanks for watching and
I'll see you next week